inaperçu jeudi sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale une modification a
été publiée précisant que depuis le 1er
juillet bien indemnité versé au
parlementaire a été augmentée les
députés et les sénateurs ils bénéficient
désormais d'une indemnité de un peu plus
de 7493 euros brut contre
7239 euros soit une augmentation de 254
euros brut environ
170 euros net avec cette augmentation et
bien la rémunération de nos
parlementaires pèse plus de 164 millions
d'euros charges sociales inclus dans le
budget 2022 soit prêt d'un milliard
d'euros sur la durée du quinquennat
Gilles Verdez
même si c'est automatique parce que
c'est une catégorie de fonctionnaires
ils auraient dû refuser ils auraient dû
faire un vote eux qui votent pour
n'importe quoi ils auraient dû faire un
vote commun avec les sénateurs on refuse
vous rend compte aujourd'hui les gens
souffrent et eux ils sont augmentés mais
parce que là on a donné leur enveloppe
mais vous ajoutez Cyril vous allez
halluciner
10950 3 euros par mois pour leur
collaborateurs et plein d'indemnités de
transport de communication ils nous
coûtent des fortunes oui je trouve ça
scandaleux vas-y Daniel non mais moi je
suis en train de lire tous les avantages
ils ont 80 voyages par an en avion ils
ont moi vous savez voilà je
ne suis pas un plafond c'est-à-dire que
au dessus de 4000 euros personne ne
touche et on met 4 % pour tous ceux qui
ont moins de 4000 euros pour les
fonctionnaires parce que j'en ai marre
que ce soit des trucs automatiques on se
retrouve avec des députés eux-mêmes qui
trouvent que c'est pas normal
ah calme-toi vas-y tu vas rentrer dans
ta chambre non mais il y a des députés
qui trouvent eux-mêmes qui sont très
bien payés et c'est pas normal qu'ils
aient ces 3,5% de de d'augmentation
c'est une augmentation automatique ne la
faisons plus automatique faisant une
augmentation un peu plus grosse pour moi
de gens pour les gens qui ont non mais
moins de 4000 ans parce que là
ils sont déjà extrêmement bien payés ils
ont plein d'avantages on leur augmente
encore plus prendre augmente pas une
infirmière ou quelqu'un d'autre qui en a
dans le besoin tu intervenir
qu'est-ce que je viens de dire
et il n'est pas payé
[Applaudissements]
en fait ils font partie des
fonctionnaires de la catégorie a donc
automatiquement tous les fonctionnaires
peu importe qu'ils sont députés ou pas
ont été augmenté de 3,5 %, parce que
c'est lié à l'inflation et en fait ce
qu'ils auraient dû faire c'est de
effectivement voter entre eux et de dire
on refuse cette augmentation à titre
symbolique en disant les autres
fonctionnaires de la catégorie A très
bien qu'il prenne cette augmentation
mais nous on est déjà rémunéré à 7200
7200 euros c'est largement suffisant
cette année on passe notre tour ils ont
voté les nucs là les écolos le PC tout
ça là ils ont ils ont ils ont
l'impression
c'était parce que
vous avez voté Jean-Luc Mélenchon
alors le seul qui trouve pas ça qu'on se
connaît le c'est mon ami cassé normal
tous pourris les politiques
c'est un peu ça c'est des qu'ils ont une
rotation dit voilà c'est ils sont tous
pourris ils ont ils moi je préfère un
député qui est bien payé et qui va pas
piquer dans la caisse que le pays moins
pour qu'elle aille faire
preuve c'est trop facile en plus voilà
c'est bien français il faut critiquer
les députés il faut critiquer les
politiques on devient voleur bah non
mais tu sais très bien que c'est comme
ça tu sais très bien que les politiques
ont eu tendance à appliquer dans la
caisse donc c'est pas on les payant
moins qu'ils vont moins le faire
maintenant c'est un argument c'est un
argument qui a été avancé c'est un
argument qui était avancé très souvent
effectivement et que si on payait moins
les points de vie qui se répliquer dans
laquelle monsieur
demande argument et encore une fois ce
qui est très important c'est les
symboles dans un pays quand on peut pas
faire grand-chose pour calmer le peuple
les gens et tout ça ce sont des symboles
et là où Valérie a raison c'est
qu'effectivement les 250 euros ça ne
changera pas leur vie contrairement à
beaucoup de gens et en revanche les
refuser c'est montrer un symbole c'est
montrer que c'est difficile pour tout le
monde et que évidemment on se demande
pas le fait que ce soit augmenté cette
hallucinant et effectivement j'ai la
raison il y a des enveloppes il faut
savoir de cash à côté ils ont des
enveloppes gigantesques pour leur faux
frais à côté jusqu'à 10000 11000 euros
les restaurants payés les vestes payées
les costumes payés ils ont quand même
des vies de rêve donc effectivement oui
c'est une honte Bernard Montiel non il a
raison sauf que les costumes
il a bien dit sauf que les costumes sont
pas payés mais en revanche les frais de
transport la voiture avec chauffeur et
tout le machin mais c'est toute
l'assemblée c'est-à-dire c'est tous les
parties bien sûr concernés évidemment je
tiens le soulier allez c'est pour ça que
ça ça tient pas forcément si on a étudié
au bout d'un moment passe une partie là
dessus ils sont ils s'entendent tous les
sénateurs aussi d'ailleurs
19000 € annuels de frais de bureautique
et de communication qui a ça aujourd'hui
c'est ça franchement quand on voit les
abonnements téléphoniques
incroyable non mais c'est délirant c'est
impossible de continuer comme ça les
retraites qui sont garanties après pour
les sénateurs c'est impossible on peut
pas continuer comme ça merci on peut pas
continuer comme ça on va voir ce qu'on
pense c'était les spectateurs tiens ah
bah oui attends non à 8 %